Rachel starts off this hour in
California hi Rachel
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show my
babies how are you better than I deserve
what's up in your world so my question
is about my student loan I graduated
about five years ago
and I was paying them down for quite a
bit I was paying in excess of you know
$1,000 on my monthly payments but I
recently got a an apartment in August so
paying towards them has you know
decreased immensely and I've also tried
consolidating them to get a better rate
but I've been rejected everywhere that I
go so I'm just trying to figure out what
to do at this point how does it where
were you living before I was living with
my grandparents for a few years yeah and
what five I'm sorry like five yeah it
was it was about three it was about
three to four years yeah been our school
for five right yes but I wasn't living
with them right after school right cool
okay so how much was your apartment rent
it's 1450 that's a big jump
yeah it was okay what's in here yeah and
what city are you in I'm in Fullerton
California it's close to LA yeah okay
and what is your income it's about it's
between 40 and 45 kind of my payment is
really high what's your what's your
balance yeah it's ridiculous what's the
balance on your student loans um right
now with that 22 I got it down from
about 35 to 22 good for you okay so we
were putting a thousand dollars a month
on the student loans and now we're
spending that and then some on rent
correct okay there's not any magic pill
that gets you out of student loan debt
big Harry
payments get you in student loan bad
debt and so we have to reverse the
mathematics that have occurred here
somehow
you know truthfully the rent you're
paying for the area you're in is not you
know completely brain-damaged crazy but
as a percentage of your income and that
and that causing you to be able to do
nothing else is is a problem so you're
probably got to rethink your housing
sooner rather than later it's not a good
long-term plan to pay 1450 well you have
student loan debt or not to pay 1450
when you make 40 grands so we've either
got to get your income up or your outgo
down temporarily the way you get income
up as you work more an extra job or six
and what do you do for a living
um so I have a full-time job as a credit
associate and then I do work Starbucks
and like a side hustle part-time so I'm
working about 6065 hours a week yeah but
you're not making anything at they'll
say at that Starbucks gig what are they
paying you 10 bucks mm-hmm yeah well
there's like 12 yeah yeah you're not
making enough to fool with that you got
to make some money we need to make some
money
we didn't make some real money yeah you
make a lot more than a Starbucks
babysitting right well so so my plan
right now like I'm working full-time as
a credit so she you know about 20
dollars a little over 20 dollars an hour
yeah but I am trying again to the police
academy come February I'm taking a test
so hope you know if I get that that'll
increase my yeah okay I income let's do
that and in the meantime let's look for
better side hustles okay that make you
some money I mean let's make it actually
here's an idea you dropped fourteen
hundred bucks a month let's go make
fourteen hundred a month and the
thousand dollars a month on your student
loans in 22 months they're gone great so
not even two years of sad hustles
because you work a lot hours you're not
afraid of work you just got sucky jobs
great so let's just go make some money
so that we can get Sallie Mae out of
that apartment and I love your idea
moving towards the police academy is
your long-term
upgrade your long-term gig there's two
ways we make more money so there's a
short-term which is you know side
hustles and some of those don't they're
temporary so don't have to be pleasant
they don't have to be part of your
career moves and then long-term you
think about what do I want to be and the
next phase of my life what I want to be
when I'm 50 years old 60 years old 40
years old what do I want to be then that
makes double what I'm making now and so
let's let's be aiming at something
because exhibiter used to say if you aim
at nothing you'll hit it every time so
your problem is a fairly simple problem
Rachel it's you raised your expenses 49
or 50 bucks a month and voila you didn't
have any money to put on the student
loans so we've got to raise our income
by that much and probably long term
address this housing situation so that's
your offset